there is a change machine ATM and when I
over here I noticed that there's a
little bit of glue and just to you can
see it right here and just because I'm
paranoid with cyber security I decid
just to go ahead and give us a tug and
I'll let you hear so you actually comes
right off this is very well made you can
see it's an exact replica uh actually
know hold on man don't do that this is
actually a skimmer that actually steals
credit cards this one right here you can
tell is
safe cuz you can't take this off this
right here would steal someone's credit
card so you're welcome yeah so so have
you just found out I just found this out
and I'm going to go try to see what I
can do about reverse engineering
this